how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and next month is ccxp the Comic-Con
experience and it has been confirmed
that Marvel Studios will be attending
ccxb having their own panel talking
about upcoming projects and according to
some insiders there are some surprises
that are waiting for us at ccxb coming
from Marvel Studios now those surprises
could be anything from a new trailer to
a couple of new trailers to the complete
reveal of the entirety of Marvel's Phase
6 slate which they have only revealed
three projects for now we technically
know four projects now confirmed for
Marvel's phase six because of Deadpool
3. however that came after the reveal of
the three projects for phase six at San
Diego Comic-Con however concerning the
entirety of phase six the big question
was why did Marvel Studios decide to
only reveal three projects for phase six
and what could the other projects be
well that's what we'll talk about today
what could possibly be revealed at ccxb
coming up next month and also if you're
new be sure to to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and Marvel
reveals now to start off we do know that
when Marvel typically reveals a face
slate they reveal the entire thing not
only part of it but for our case at San
Diego Comic-Con they revealed the
entirety of Phase 5 and then some of
phase six and we do actually know why
they only revealed three projects for
phase six and that is because they
actually got leaked ahead of time they
actually got leaked the day before San
Diego Comic-Con and three names were
leaked Captain America New World Order
Avengers the Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars these three were literally
leaked the day before San Diego
Comic-Con so it's almost like Disney had
their hands tied and had to get ahead of
the leaks and just decided to announce
them themselves so this is most likely
why we only got three projects for phase
six and of course we already knew the
Fantastic Four were coming Kevin feige
has confirmed that multiple times they
just confirmed the release date date for
us which was nice but now seeing as how
some surprises might be coming at ccxp
we're looking forward to what the rest
of the phase six slate is at ccxp they
could reveal the entirety of the Slate
or they could reveal some projects that
are going to be coming in phase six just
not the entire thing but now it does
seem like it's time to reveal the rest
we are almost in 2023 which means phase
six is just about two years away so what
movies and projects could realistically
be coming in phase six well like I said
we already know four projects and really
we actually know five projects coming in
phase six we have Deadpool 3 The
Fantastic Four Avengers Secret Wars
Avengers King Dynasty and armor Wars
which is now going to be made into a
movie not a Disney Plus show now we know
arm rewards is going to tie into secret
Invasion and most likely the
Thunderbolts and Captain America new
world order as well after all Roadie was
in the Falcon and the Winter Soldier he
was talking to Sam about becoming the
new Captain America and now Sam is the
new captain in America so I would expect
Roadie to be in that film or at least
mentioned so as of right now we have
five confirmed movies coming in phase
six what other movies and shows could be
coming not to mention special
presentations now of course everybody
wants to know about the X-Men and the
mutants and of course I do too I want
the mutants in the MCU very very badly
however I don't actually think they're
coming until phase seven based off of
everything that we've heard so far it
sounds like Kevin feige has plans to
introduce new X-Men characters and
mutants after Secret Wars but before
then we are still going to get mutants
and we'll still have an X-Men team
however these X-Men are going to be
coming from the fox universe and
apparently this is all going to start
with Deadpool According to some recent
rumors and leaks Deadpool is going to
bring a lot of X-Men into the MCU and
this is kind of going to be Kevin
feige's way of saying goodbye to the
X-Men Kevin feige started with Marvel by
working on the the X-Men and Spider-Man
films he's worked on the original X-Men
Spider-Man with Sam Raimi the Fantastic
Four The Punisher he's worked with
Marvel for a very very long time before
he was the president of Marvel Studios
he started as an associate producer and
worked his way up so Kevin feige worked
on all of these old what we call the fox
Universe films and the Sam Raimi
Spider-Man films what a perfect way for
him to truly say goodbye to this
universe by him putting them in the new
universe plus not to mention many of
these old actors from these old Marvel
movies said that they wish they had a
chance to be in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe well this is their way of being
in the universe then the actors in Kevin
foggy could say goodbye but having said
that I think that means that no new
X-Men and mutant characters are going to
be introduced in a big way and what I
mean by that is obviously we have seen
Namor is a mutant we have seen that
Kamala Khan although not a mutant in the
comics is a mutant in the MCU so yes
marvelous Studios will start talking
about mutants in the MCU before Phase 6
ends however I don't think the true team
is coming until phase seven so
unfortunately in phase six I don't think
there's a mutant project scheduled
however I would love to be wrong however
there are some projects that are
confirmed that we know to be coming in
phase six and I am really really excited
for them the first one of course is
Spider-Man 4. what we know so far about
Spider-Man 4 is that the deal for
Spider-Man to remain in the MCU is
pretty much done if not already done the
New Deal is rumored to be for six movies
three movies that are Solo Spider-Man
films and three team-up films with one
possibly being for an appearance in a
show possibly Daredevil born again that
would make the most sense now there is a
tiny possibility this could get revealed
at ccxp however typically Sony is the
one to reveal anything about Spider-Man
and they have confirmed they are not
attending ccxp this year however we know
it's going to be a part of phase six now
another one that has been confirmed is
Nova now this isn't going to be a movie
it's not going to be a show but a
special presentation is what has been
said recently if you've kept up with the
channel you know that I think special
presentations to introduce new
characters are actually a really good
idea I think it worked extremely well
with werewolf by night so having Nova
introduced into the MCU as a special
presentation I'm all for it now we know
from Avengers Infinity war that Thanos
decimated xandar which means the Nova
force is most likely on its way to Earth
to collide with Richard Ryder this just
makes the most sense continuity wise
plus lining up with the comics as well
so I'm assuming this is somewhat of what
we'll see in the special presentation
now xiangxi 2 has also been confirmed
they confirmed this after the first film
came out and see malio the actor who
plays shangchi has pretty much confirmed
that he's going to be popping up in
other places before Avengers Secret Wars
happens so perhaps they'll show up in
other projects but we can assume since
the second Shang Chi has already been
confirmed that it'll happened before
Avengers Secret Wars especially if you
consider Kang probably has something to
do with the tin rings so they'll have to
explore that before the movie comes out
and I am talking about the artifacts not
the actual tin Rings organization which
will be a show in Disney plus about his
sister running the 10 Rings organization
we also know that a Wonder Man show is
going to be coming this is going to be a
Disney Plus show and based off of what
we've heard this is going to be coming
in phase six and recently variety has
revealed that Marvel has cast Yaya Abdul
Mateen to be Wonder Man himself so since
they've already cast him this is most
likely coming pretty soon it actually
could come in Phase five just because it
seems like they've revealed all of phase
five already doesn't mean that they
can't add other projects in after the
fact but it is pretty cramped so far and
they haven't started filming or anything
like that yet so I'm still thinking it's
coming in phase six now another one is
Doctor Strange three now Doctor Strange
3 is confirmed however it's not
confirmed that the movie will come in
phase six however we are taking an
educated guess here considering the fact
that secret Wars is going to be about
the Multiverse and incursions and the
post-credits scene for Doctor Strange 2
spoiler alert was Clea showing up
telling doctor strange that he caused an
incursion and they needed to go fix it
so clearly Doctor Strange 3 is going to
have a pretty big impact on what the
Multiverse actually is and all of the
incursions happening so it's most likely
safe to assume that this will come out
before Secret Wars so realistically
these are projects that have been
officially confirmed that are most
likely coming in phase six so hopefully
since Marvel Studios has some surprises
in store for us at ccxp we could get
some information about some of these
maybe all of them but I wouldn't expect
too much don't get expectations too high
and I do want to add a little bonus here
a Silver Surfer presentation has been
rumored to be in the works at Marvel
Studios as well this is not confirmed so
we're not going to say that it's going
to be a part of phase six but if it does
end up happening it will most likely end
up in phase six however like I said not
confirmed but let me know your thoughts
about all of these other projects in the
comments down below and let me know your
thoughts on the original X-Men appearing
in the MCU don't forget to like the
video and subscribe stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf